welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm really excited to be joined by
ross fraser who is the managing director
of connecting experts
who are a specialist within the future
mobility space
and are on a mission to be the number
one global talent acquisition partner
within this industry
ross entered the recruitment industry in
2011 where he joined
chapman black over the five years he was
there he progressed from delivery
consultant all the way to
becoming the head of a division then in
2016
he left to start his own recruitment
business which is when connecting
experts was formed
and over the last five years ross has
been really focused on growing
that business they're currently at 20
heads have big growth plans
and last year turned over 1.4 um
million as a business in 2020. ross
thanks for joining me
hi how are you good good i'm looking
forward to this
so so obviously for those that may not
put this together
ross is the brother of jamie who started
interacting i've had in this podcast
yeah told that you guys are competitive
so i won't i won't let you know who gets
the most downloads
yeah well i i look myself and i'm sure
as well now that you've mentioned that
he's the younger brother in case anyone
wanted to know as well
love that well i'm excited to really
unpack your journey so where we always
like to start is
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think make up a
highly successful recruitment consultant
yeah it's a good question because
everyone's different
um and eve and it's only sort of
over the last year or so that i've
started to really like drill down and
really look at different people and
what's worked and what hasn't worked
um i think it all depends what partly
depends on the type of recruitment that
you do but like for example in our space
like
it and in a startup environment in
particular it's really really important
that we get people that are
like mini entrepreneurs in their own
right and people that
have the thought process to
want to be successful themselves and
they have goals and visions and that
sort of stuff so
i think definitely like goal-oriented
people that have
clear objectives and clear ambition to
do something
with purpose in their life i think
that's that's definitely like a
characteristic which is fundamental um
from from a work perspective it's all to
do with
doing more than what the person next
year is doing
a consistent basis and i think that the
good thing is if you get yourself into
an environment where
i was lucky obviously in my career sort
of work like that but if you get
yourself into an environment where
people are
doing really really well and they're
earning good money and
you know you you feel motivated by the
people that are around you
and if you target yourself to be better
than those people then obviously you
know you'll end up sort of
well hopefully you'll end up doing well
so i think that
you know motivate people in the sense of
you know doing what they want to do and
going in that direction and being quite
ruthless
you know and there are words that people
use like ruthless
and um aggressive and all that sort of
stuff which
can be seen in a negative light but they
are actually quite
positive words if you look at it in the
right way like if you're
ruthless with your time and you're
ruthless with your effort and you are
um engaged enough to be successful
it doesn't necessarily matter it doesn't
matter but it's not
the main focus how good you are at
something if you're really drilling down
that sort of stuff yeah and aggressive
is is all to do with
again like that relentless approach um
on wanting to achieve something so
you know just from a a personality
perspective i think those are the things
that i would sort of look at
yeah i love that so look obviously what
we're going to really unpack
and focus on is definitely ross being a
recruitment business owner and growing
the business you have over the last five
years but let's just touch on
sort of um ross being an employee and
being a
recruiter yourself so i guess like how
would you i'm always interested but like
how would you
describe your first year in recruitment
like what what what was that like
uh like a bit of a whirlwind because it
was i was
how old was that i was 18 just about to
turn 19.
yeah and i joined this company which was
like two entrepreneurs that had sold a
business before
um really engaged team and i was the
youngest at the time
so it was like how old is it
i started in january and then i turned
19 in february
um i did i did like an internship for
the first three months
really yeah yeah so they paid my
expenses but i wasn't actually paid
and i remember the guy that hired me
said to me
you need to show to us why we should
hire you versus a graduate
if that makes sense um and
yeah i think you know i'm boiling it
back down to like what i what i really
focused on at the time and
what what i like i was really nervous
and
people that know me now would think that
that's not possible but
i was really i found it difficult to
talk in front of people i found it
difficult to
um my my interviews must have been
terrible but if i interviewed myself
now then it i could imagine but the
first year was
was really progressive for me because
you know i started to
again focus on those things i was
aggressive but in the right way i was
proactive in the right way i was hungry
to be successful
um and you know it it sort of went
like i saw i felt myself like develop as
a person in that year quite
significantly and their coaching and
training was really really good and it
really helped because you have people to
look up to
yeah well it sounds like what you're
talking about there is confidence
and like a bit of self-belief
let's just let's just talk about that
real quick because i think
i think i speak to loads of recruiters
and i think i'm sure i
maybe may not agree but i feel like even
people that are really experienced still
experience that and that self-doubt or
imposter syndrome or whatever so i guess
where did that cut like i don't know how
did you i guess it seemed like what you
did is like you recognized that then you
like channeled energy into things that
i don't know pushed you on and like you
said but i don't know where did
why do you think you lacked confidence
out of interest and
uh why i think i think that
like everyone leaves school and yeah
well
everyone leaves school staff
some earlier than others um but i think
i think the point the point is is that i
left school with no idea what i was
actually going to do yeah
and i started to work for an estate
agent and when i was 17 and i was like
this is not what i want to do
like i cut like the people no disrespect
to the people that work there but the
people that worked there had already
worked there for quite a long time
they're still there to this day at the
same estate agent's
instructor yeah it's like i don't i
don't see myself doing that
um like long term so i was sort of
like i found it difficult to then sort
of think what am i going to do and and
how how am i going to be pressure isn't
that yeah it's hard it's hard like
my mum's a single single mom not that
that that really matters certain you
know loads of people in that situation
but
i think it's hard to it's hard to then
feel that you're the right you're in the
right situation or that you're
you're going to be good enough if that
makes sense and i know that
i know that that is how other people
must feel
um and
i think when you go into an environment
and you see other people you see how
confident they are and
how good they are at what they do you
you start to
just not everyone's yeah you start to
compare and doubt yourself
um and looking back at it that's the
complete opposite of what you should do
if you focus
on what you do compare observe take
things
that you like but if you really focus on
what you can do
people are talented enough to achieve
that and i think that that's
that's the main reason why at the start
i was really really nervous if that
makes sense
and i think and and even now like even
now some things i think like war
when i sit back and i sort of work out
like what
where we want to get to and i think well
like
is that even logical uh
but again you've got to stick to the
principles yeah no thank you for sharing
that and
the the reason why i wanted to talk
about that was because i think a point
that you made earlier that people may
view now and may not even know
that's how you were at the beginning
right so i think it's important so this
is all about but also
i'm sure now hiring for your team and
business like you probably see
some of this you may see some of you
early on in people as well so i guess
the next part that i would love and you
may have already sort of touched it on
the comparison thing but i guess
there'll be a lot of people listen to
this that may still lack that confidence
or may
still not um yeah they didn't turn it on
or they didn't
then change it so i guess for you what
what clicked like when did you when did
you then
actually maybe you turned that into well
no i'm going to stop using that as a
reason i said why i should be confident
i'm going to re
turn into a reason why i'm motivated to
be confident and be i don't know like
what clip for you to
sort of yeah yeah channel that in a
different way i think
like i i'm i'm competitive as a person
right so
it was good how it's set up so that i
was in a room with other people that
started with me
and we focused on uh like number
generation
and yeah we had certain kpis it was only
small it was like
call time and um outbound calls and and
stuff like that and
i was just like every day i don't care
what happened i just want to be
top of these top of those yeah top of
those points
um and i think over over quite a quick
period of time
and i see it with other people that are
high over now you
you start to understand i can do this
like it's not actually that difficult
momentum
yeah yeah yeah yeah and obviously you
get knockbacks everyone gets knocked
back but
i think that process was was was really
really useful
um so yeah again like
i just always focus on what i or tried
to focus on i could influence in that
day and in that
hour and whatever and yeah okay
no i love that so i guess couple of
things
one like obviously you progressed
obviously quite
quite quickly in those five years so i
guess obviously
obviously it didn't end up turning out
all well for chapman black which
everyone was
sawing everyone was aware but i guess at
the time and where you were as i'm sure
you would look to the business like wow
i'm surrounded by
yeah really um high-performing people
and these types of things so
i think it'd be fair to say that it was
a highly competitive environment
so i'm always interested to because we
all hear recruiters and
and people say that i want to progress
my career right but few actually do it
so i guess i'm just interested to ask
you like why
do you think russ was the person that
was able to get the promotions that you
was
over the person sitting next to you uh
again i i think it comes it comes back
to like the principles of just trying to
be better than the people around you
and trying to do like we we we only
when i was there we only started time we
were only doing roles in germany
at a point and we're only doing so like
medium-sized fees and stuff and like
medium size and we do is like 15
20k um so it was it was
from my perspective i always wanted to
push the boundaries like i did the
the best first six months in in as a
delivery consultant
um build 150k in the first six months as
a sales consultant
um and then it sort of at a period of
time i was always trying to push
the barrier in terms of okay i want to
be a practice manager before anyone else
becomes a practice manager i want to be
the youngest practice manager in the
company
i want the the team then to be the the
the number one team in terms of profit
profitability within the business
and then it became the group and then
whatever else so it's always like at
every step there needs to be
an opportunity to develop even further
um
and that that's the reason why when i
when
i think back about the reasons why i set
up connecting experts it was because
i then felt that i had no further to
actually go
um become which becomes the the
motivation so
why for me like recruiters are very good
at talking a good game
that's their job um but the
the substance is the important part and
there's there's loads of really really
good recruiters out there and i think
that they
do the simple things and set simple
goals that are
realistic but you know um
what's the word that realistic but
challenging for them to go and achieve
and
and that for me is always the difference
between good and bad
yeah or good on average just just a
point on what because i think it's
interesting just a point on what
so clearly that's your point around
being looking for people that are goal
oriented and they're clearly
you build momentum built confidence and
then you're like right i'm going to
absolutely smash this and
achieve these targets that no one's ever
done etc etc and that kept you going
until a point
i think i had someone on here not too
long ago where he said the most
consistent and high-performing
recruiters were able to
actually dust themselves off and
actually remain motivated despite having
an absolute
quality month and then do it all again
the following month he said some people
that weren't as consistent
got complacent and weren't able to do
that so i guess what i wanted to ask you
with you sharing that
i know you said it got to a point where
you was probably a bit more demotivated
which is maybe what started the business
idea point but
how for people listening there are
because i'm sure you have people in your
business now that are showing up every
month
smashing it like how did you keep
yourself motivated because that's the
that's an important part to make isn't
it because you smash these targets then
it's like right okay well
what now then like you need to keep that
motivation you know what i mean
yeah i think anyone who's got themselves
into like a top
so when you start i think it's all about
earning commission and you work on
commission and you hit your target and
okay now i've got now i'm starting to
earn money which is the whole reason why
one of the main reasons why people get
into recruitment then once you start to
earn money
it's like okay well i'm now saving
towards xyz
and then once you start saving towards
it to a dead you buy your house whatever
it may be
whatever it can be anything i think then
you start to
develop um ambitions which are not
necessarily
monetary but more about your career if
that makes sense and more about
okay well what can i do with this group
of people or
what can i challenge myself and you know
is there is there like companies that do
like incent incentives and
which you know loads do and companies
that do top biller prizes and whatever
that's that's then that's then what
should and would become your focus it's
not the only thing
but it so it then steps away from how
much money am i earning because
it kind of becomes obvious that you
learn money because you've done that for
so long if that
sounds stupid but it does and then you
start to i believe that you start to
really focus on
other things and that's why companies
have to give i
i think now more than ever people good
clear career progression
um you know share options opportunities
to to have ownership of the company
to build things for open offices
whatever it may be there has to be
something but that relationship with
your your management or your
manager or whatever it may be is
important because they should understand
what is motivating that person to be
successful because everyone has
different opinions
yeah no i love that so look final thing
on this then
like if you could um if you could go
back and
i'll always love ask this question so if
you could go back
and speak to ross who was entering the
recruitment industry in 2011.
yeah what what what advice would you
give them don't be so cocky
but you just said you know you said you
wasn't yeah well i went from one
i went from all right fair really
yeah what would you say then don't be
cocky be stay grounded stay humble
yeah i think stay stay stay focused on
like you know he said about
uh like recruiters that consist like
consistency
is is is what top villains do and
they're always
always feeling regardless if they have a
good or a bad a bad month for a top bill
is like
30k and you think that's still quite
good
um but yeah i think if i look back at
you know when i went into sales i did
150k
as a as a sales consultant um in the
first six months in the first
three months there was no threshold and
the sales the the
commission at chapman black was pretty
good so i was all of a sudden i was 19
and i was earning a lot of money
um so you start going out and stuff and
you start
becoming like jack the lad in the pub
and whatever else and uh
i think that my
biggest like i've had some of the best
nights ever in that way but my biggest
regret if i look at myself as a person
but everyone does this
like you get sort of uh you look back at
your night and you think
we should never do that yeah yeah but i
think that the point is that
be having that sort of arrogance at a
time it was too much
it shouldn't arrogance is good again
like it comes back to the other things
that
these things are good in small doses uh
yeah but i think just like a young
like a lot of young boys i was i was two
too boisterous if that makes sense and i
i wish i'd i wish if i looked to myself
now and
i've got people that work for me and
i'll just say to them i know exactly
what you're like and
you need to you need to listen to me and
uh yeah that's what i will show us more
um
that's why i would tell myself anyway no
no thank you for sharing that i think
because i find it really interesting
right because it's like you everything
that you're talking about it's like
i know it's it's your responsibility to
go
to make those decisions but sometimes
you didn't need a bit of guidance
and i think that's something that i
don't know i i'd like to see more
sort of recruitment business owners do
where like you know that
that 19 year old in your business has
gone from not making much to 50
68 grand and that that's a lot of money
that age and i think it'd be great if
people
could actually spend a bit of time going
look do what you want to do i've been in
your shoes
but this is what i wish i did with my
money at that age if that's
putting in the stocks and shares ice or
whatever it may be
i don't know i'd love to see some actual
financial guidance to people where
like i know those people like you just
said if you you would probably be if you
were to say that to
the younger ross you'd probably be
thanking thanking yourself right now
that you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah
i i agree
and i think that that's the beauty of
being like still quite young myself and
having
a a relationship with people that work
with
me and i think i think there has to be
again you have to i
have to create that environment which is
aspiring for people and
yeah you know obviously i aspire to do
whatever and
you know even even you know if you take
jamie for example
he's really good inspiration for for how
he looks at his
life ladies he's like super regimented
which is which is something
to look at and to be thinking of so
within my business now i think it's
important
like for me it's important that we the
managers and
they build good relationships they they
understand what what the people
want to do not just about money but what
they actually want to do with their
career
um and and try to give them as much
advice as possible
um but yeah it's hard it's hard it's
hard to convince
a 19 year old who's just done his first
commission check
don't spend that on whatever you're
going to spend it on
um yeah yeah yeah i think i think the
fact that i think that yeah i think
that's great that you're having those
conversations and encouraging that
i think that's awesome so so let's get
into rus ross starting connecting
experts then and starting this business
so that's a
completely different ball game from
being an employee
like knowing we need to do so talk to us
about
i guess why don't we just start with a
lot of people speak down with their
mates and around the pub and whatever
and go i'm gonna start my own
recruitment business one day but never
actually do it so
i guess what what gave you the courage i
think the 19 year old me who probably
said that several times
if i don't do it i'm going to get ripped
for the rest of my life so i'm just
happy i think
but um no honey honey
honest answer is uh two there's two
parts so
one i didn't feel like there was any
further for me to go at chapman black
i think which i think was was obviously
a big part um
and two was um my mum said to me and
jamie one day why don't you both start a
recruitment company you both did really
regularly
yeah basically basically she has 10 of
both of our companies
which i love that i didn't know that
yeah
yeah yeah um we've got the rest but she
has 10 so
um so there was no way that we were
going to be able to start a business
together
um as much as the idea of it was great
he
he comes from a contract background i'm
all perm and
retained searches and stuff like that so
how we work and
our opinions on how to work are
different markets as well isn't it
yeah exactly so so long story short is
we we took an office where we live um
like shoe box like half the size of if
they're
probably a quarter of the size of this
kitchen um
and uh 450 pound a month whatever and uh
yeah we started and
i'll be honest the hardest part at the
start
was motivation
in the sense in the sense of i've been
in an environment where there's loads of
people around me
and it's easy like someone's doing
really well it's easy to see yourself
asking to be motivated
if things are hard in that environment
they are hard
yeah um the beauty was jamie is
super like boom boom boom boom
yeah yeah so it that made it easier
but i'd say that was this for me the
biggest challenge at the start
um could we just talk about that for a
second because i hear this a lot so
i i've spoken to and worked with a lot
of
sort of smaller business owners and i
hear this a lot and it's
i think some people would be surprised
wouldn't they because they think well
ross you've just started your own
business how can you not be motivated
but
it's a bit deeper than that isn't it
some of the things that you just said
and it's actually like you've been used
to bouncing off people
and stuff like that whereas now it's
like every single minute of the day
you've got to motivate yourself and i've
i've struggled that with at times and
what i've had to
really be clear on is really
understanding like why i'm doing what
i'm doing
because i think sometimes you can get
really you can just very easily
just get nailed down in like the day to
day and knowing what you need to get
done
and sometimes you can forget like right
why the [ __ ] did i start this again like
why did i actually go on this journey
yeah what obviously you had jamie which
helps but i don't know what
what because i'm sure you had to really
tap into your motivation and stuff like
what what ended up really
sort of picking your motivation up or
what did you go to to help you get
motivated i think i think the um i think
a big thing at the time was
to do with uh
again going back to sort of like my
start and how i wanted to be was like i
always knew i wanted to be successful
and i
never quantified what success meant at
the time because yeah 23 when i started
um
connecting experts and
i just thought well like okay how
how can i get this the other thing i had
a six month
non-compete obviously so i i i started
by doing something
not completely different but i've done
automotive for the whole time i've been
in recruitment and then i've stepped out
of that for six months
so i was recruiting obviously i was
doing searches still
for the same skill set but in a
different industry yeah
so i just took that as a challenge again
we sort of like took that as a goal as
for something that i could try to do to
try to
build a bit of a brand um outside of
automotive because that was going to
come
and yeah it's just like okay let's
let's let's challenge myself let's find
something um
and people like maybe people do but i
i wasn't the type of person that was
going to be able to sit in an office for
12 hours a day every day not speaking to
anyone
in terms of like socially interacting
just speaking to
it it just that wasn't for me and that's
that's why
that's why you know i can imagine people
find that locked down tough because if
they're not socially interacting with
people
not everyone some people can do it but
that's tough
um so it was just like okay let's go and
win a position
and let's let's make sure that we fill
that position and um
luckily enough things started to fall
into place
um yeah and how long did it take
i don't undertake if you do your first
deal uh six weeks
so i wanna i want i wanna retain them
quite early on so basically what i did
is i went down all my links in contact
and i took out all the i didn't take
them out but i called all the ones that
weren't
automotive and i called this one guy
um and he was like yeah we're looking
for a
like a chief purchasing officer for our
business building materials business in
belgium so
like i rang my mum was like i've got to
go to belgium to meet these guys
um she's like okay why are you calling
me
um just go so i went
down the business trip to belgium i've
got a
like basically i i made
like the typical retainer was like a
third third third is that yeah
yeah so i just said like okay just pay
me 10
000 euros up front and then i'll do a
fixed fee for the rest because i'll just
try i'll do whatever
it takes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah get
that we've got his back yeah yeah and uh
yeah
luckily that you know the search was
successful and um i still work with some
of the people that are there now
so um and then it was just a case of
like you know
momentum yeah yeah yeah and we started
to hire we hired a hired a couple of
people in that year and uh yeah it was
good
love that so let's just because you've
mentioned it like just real quick and
you can
like how how much of your business is
retained
uh depend depends which part
so i'd say a third probably so yeah 30
roughly yeah yeah definitely so just a
quick one on that and i'm sure you may
or may not have seen the
light i i feel like um i don't know from
the lens that i
see i feel like there's just been so
much more noise around and it's
something i've
had did you have you already done a lot
of retained at chapman black and that
was the environment
yeah i just feel like a lot of people
are just
making so much noise online around like
contingent is dead and all this sort of
stuff so i
so i guess for you like in your opinion
like why do you think um a lot of
recruiters struggle to transition into
retained
or like i don't know okay so
i think people people like if you've
never pitched a retainer
it's like asking someone for money up
front that
that it's completely against how you've
worked before if that makes sense
yeah yeah it's like breaking the mould
of what you've been used to
um and someone put it quite nicely from
the
for me before if you build a brand and
you build a reputation
and you are good at what you do um
you don't go into apple or you can now
but you don't go into apple
and say give me that phone i'll pay you
when it when i've used it
i mean you buy the phone and then you
use it um
and it's a service but it's a service
that should guarantee results and if
you're good at what you do you should be
able to articulate that in a way where
where it can come across but that's for
that's for an experienced person like
that an experienced person should know
that
i think that there are loads of
techniques that you can use to sell a
retained search
and i think that it's more specific for
like 80k
90k plus salaries you're not going to be
able to sell a retaining search
necessarily for like
a blue collar engineer unless maybe it's
like volume maybe
it might be like actually maybe maybe
but i think i think i think the thing
the thing that
everyone well people should i always
look at and and
it's it's a it's a solution right so
there's there's
hiring problems is that what a company
needs and why they need it and i think
that if you're able to question that and
to really understand what they need why
they need it how's that affecting them
why can't they get there et cetera et
cetera et cetera
then you can start to create a solution
that is custom
to that per that company so
is it because they haven't got any money
is it because
they've got loads of money but they just
haven't got any contact is it because
they're in a bad location whatever it
may be then you start to create the
solution so
what what i think people should start to
do
in general we start to look at not using
the word like retained and not losing
the word contingent and
rpo and whatever that may be but start
to think of solutions
that can be boxed up for a client based
on what their expectations are
um yeah and i think that you can be
creative
i think and and companies that are rigid
and don't
offer the opportunities for their
consultants to be creative
are stifling their own development and
revenue growth yeah i love that i've
i love the way that you're thinking
about that and i think and what what
that also really encourages and the only
way that you're going to be able to get
there is by being consultative
and yeah yeah and it's like you said
it's it's me and you having a
conversation around yes to hiring
but let's talk about how this actually
impacts your business and what you're
not gonna be able to achieve and where
you're going blah blah blah and
then you can actually come up with a and
you're only gonna do that if you'll be
consultative and not going right have
you got a job and
spot business and transactions 100 100
100
that the future of of like business
success
like and i think it always has been but
i think like it's more obvious now than
ever
through platforms like this and whatever
else it might be but the future of
business success is relationships and
that goes for relationships internally
that goes for relationships
uh with your customers it goes for
relationships with your suppliers
if you build good relationships and you
start to farm the relationships and you
start to learn more
about those people the opportunities for
development you know obviously
from a monetary perspective and from a
from a uh business perspective are huge
yeah love that so let's just talk a bit
about your journey in growing this
business
then so first couple of years i guess
just not because it always means
profitability but just for context like
after two years two and a half years so
halfway into your journey how
how many of you obviously started with
you and jamie in that shoebox room
and obviously had your non-compete so i
had to do other things but like
two and a half years in how many of you
guys were they where were you
like what did the business look like at
that point yeah so so
we moved from the first office just me
and jamie to an office for four people
me jamie and to others then we moved
from that office to the office group in
up to london yeah and then we had an
office for like 20 people
and we shared that um i think after sort
of two and a half years
um we were i was at sort of eight eight
seven or eight people if i remember
quickly
um and i think that the the big learning
i take from that period of time
is getting the right people into the
right spots
um getting the right people that breathe
understand learn want to be
how you are want to be you know pushing
in the right direction
i think that that's something that we
were missing a little bit at the time um
so can we talk about that because that's
such a common challenge
so like what what was it that you found
difficult was that you was hiring people
then you were like
now that like they're not right was it
you were hiring i don't know were you
still working out
what is the connecting experts culture
like i don't know what
what yeah what was difficult about it i
think i think we're still working out
like what our core markets we're gonna
gonna be and i know it sounds crazy
after two and a half years but you sort
of you sort of as a consultant or as a
principal consultant or whatever you
just
we were working on automotive but we
were just doing deals if that makes
sense and there wasn't really any
direction
um but we were doing well so there was
no need for direction at that time
and i think that there was uh well there
was but it just didn't happen
but there was a point when i
wasn't happy with how the company was
for several reasons and that was like a
eureka moment as to like
well we need to change i need to change
this
and i need to make some tough decisions
and it
i think a lot of it was that well part
of it was down to like growth like if
you think about growth and you focus on
growth and
you hire it you go okay that person
could do the job so let's bring them in
um that's wrong that shouldn't happen
um especially for the first hires like
when you're building a team
the people that you get into that team
at the start and
again this is a learning that i have it
should be the people that you
trust in undately that they're going to
be successful
and and and not just successful i mean
like they'll
they'll think they'll think the right
way they have the right
attitude again it comes back to like all
of the things
that we spoke about before um
and yeah i mean like for me that's so
important
looking back at it that's really like
so then what so so what what were some
of the main
changes that you made then going from i
think that i think fair play for you to
having the
self-awareness and willingness to be
like you know what
i don't like where this business is
going or sort of i think it needs to be
going in a
different direction like what what were
the because i think some
because i think that's can sometimes be
the challenge when you're running a
small business is like
you can get in a bit of a rut can't you
and like you yeah all of a sudden it's
like
we've been doing it this way for six
months now so i don't know what
some of that because some people may
really relate to that and they don't
know how to
maybe take the first step in the right i
don't know what were some of the first
steps that you had to
take that really enable you to get down
on that track that you was a lot more
happy with or what you felt was the
right thing to do
yeah i think the first the first thing
that that the
the first part of dealing with your
business is dealing with yourself
and feeling happy with yourself and what
you're doing
and um like i not a lot of people know
this but i had a lot of trouble
with like my personal mental health at a
time
okay i found it really difficult to like
do uh to
be alone and um yeah like
it's like a form of like um what's the
word
not adhd um ocd sorry
um yeah it
i wasn't happy with myself so i had to i
could go and
reflect on working yourself and deal
with that and and
met loads of really good people and
anyway that's that's where it started so
you have to like you have to be happy
with what you're putting into it
and before you can expect to get
something out of it
yeah just just quickly on that thank you
for sharing that really quickly
um like what a lot of people would feel
those things that you felt and
experience but may never actually reach
out for help
is is one of the like what i don't know
was there anything that
i don't know what enabled you to reach
out for help or like
start that because i think a lot of
people can still be feeling like that
and
not would have done anything about it
and anything there to share
yeah well what i think i have good
people around me like um
my girlfriend do i'm with now like she
was like meds throughout this whole
process
my mum obviously was immense throughout
the whole process and uh
i was in a fortunate position that they
were like that and um
but i think you know when the hardest
the hardest thing for people is
is to not speak about problems that they
might have
um especially you know young boys for
example i can imagine
you know just relating to himself how
difficult that would be for
people who don't want to have people you
know
rhythm about their emotions or their
feelings like
at the end of the day there should be
and there is always a structure and
people do understand
it's only when you start to articulate
like what your problems are
and they might not even be like they
might be superficial they might actually
be made up by yourself like you're not
good enough for
all that yeah i think that as soon as
you
as a person and it's a maturity thing as
well but
and there's tools and and uh
there's techniques that you can learn
and all that sort of stuff and there are
loads of really really good people out
there that can help with that sort of
stuff
but as soon as you as a person get past
that
that's when there is like a light bulb
moment
for you and and you know like when
you're stressed about something and then
all of a sudden you're not stressed and
you should decompose
yeah just like yeah just feel a lot more
loose a lot more free yeah
your body feels like like relieved of
all this pressure that's been building
up and that was the that for me was the
the big point when
connecting experts like from basically
from that point
and then from changing some of the
people and from really focusing on
right this is what we're going to do
really start to be like what i was at
the start that
really started to be super motivated and
super hungry to be successful from that
point we doubled in revenue
and in the last year we've doubled in
size um so that's been a significant
like that was a significant moment for
me
the company yeah me and the company
really
i love that thank you for sharing that
and so so basically what you shared
there was well look before
any sort of growth or the right things
happen
you're sharing they need to work on
yourself and 100 have that vulnerability
to work out where you need to work on
that
so i love that and thank you for sharing
that so i guess
let's just talk a bit about them when
you had that more clarity and you felt
more
deep like composed and like you you know
why you know why you turn up every day
like what were some of the i guess um
some of the things that you learned when
you were growing like did you get better
at hiring the right people what did that
look like
like did you then really yeah talk
about that i think i think the main
thing was to do with like okay
right so we're gonna we're gonna grow
this is our business and this is how
it's gonna grow
so let's get the right people now in the
right seats that are going to
be part of that journey and let's give
them opportunities to grow something
um it starts with just himself and
building that like sort of management
team
is just a huge step and getting those
tires right
yeah and doing whatever it takes like if
it means that you have to
pay someone more money than what you
actually want to pay them
but you strongly believe that they're
the right person do it
if you believe that that person has
goes out a lot but they're going to do
when they're in the office they are
going to do 9 100
everything you want them to do do it
keep them in as much as you can but do
it um you know just just do what's
required
at that point to get your business how
you want it to be structured
because once you have that structure the
growth opportunities for
you and your team like you can't double
in size if you don't have the right
infrastructure as simple as that um
yeah and the growth opportunities for
you and your team and for the people
around you and for them to start to see
us
to aspire to be like the managers and
stuff that comes from
getting the right people in in play and
that's why
i think that's the big you know game
changer for us as well
yeah and i think we've discussed this
quite a lot in the podcast that that's
probably like the most important layer
in the recruitment business to scale
because of the reasons that you're
talking about um because i think it can
be
it could have been quite easy for you to
get like i guess maybe people just to
help you deliver or like go down that
route rather than
like really focus on getting that
management layer or those those future
leaders so i guess how
so just to make this really clear
because this could be really practical
for people like
what how many how many people made up
how many people did you want to get
where you're like right if i get
three people four people the cons that
can really deliver on that
sort of that that management layer that
really important layer
then we can really start growing from
there like how many people did you want
to get in those seats and how many seats
were there of interest how did you
structure it
you
okay
all right you have to i think might have
to connect your audio
can you hear me yeah all good what
happened sorry
michael turned off done a manual restart
you know like when
nola when you've not dated for so long
and then all of a sudden yeah and then
it just automatically does it savage
it's all good
um we can carry on from here like are we
okay for time yeah i feel like 10-15
years
all right yeah yeah it's fine um right
let me just
i'll just restart and then i can edit
this bit out um
sorry okay we just had some
connection issues but as i was just
asking you ross i guess the question was
just to make it really practical for
people you said how important that
management layer was
all i wanted to ask you was
like how how in your eyes like how many
people did you need in those seats to
really kick that off
uh well it depends it depends how many
um
like teams you've got
right your screen your screen's gone
black sorry
sorry there you go i'm back we're good
it's okay so yeah so like it depends it
depends how many yeah
depends it depends how many how big your
team your team is and how big your teams
are that makes sense um
but we had uh we've got three big we got
three like divisions let's call them and
it was important to get the
the right heads of those teams um and
obviously has the companies grow and
it's been important to get the it's been
important to get like the right head of
operations it's been important to get
the right head of talent
um that's super important right ahead of
talent because
if you're not bringing the right people
into the company
what's your company um so yeah
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter how
big that team is
it can't be super big and it can't be
unmanageable and
you have to be able to communicate with
people on regular basis and touch points
and all that sort of stuff
um and and then obviously you know if as
long as you're covering the bases of
like your core markets i think that's
the most important part
yeah nice love that so let's just
i love the fact that you just said
around those other important positions
so at what stage
did you invest in a operations person
what at what stage did you invest in a
internal talent post because i think
that's i think a lot of businesses
smaller growing businesses
think oh now that that's someone like
that's that's for a bigger business
right it's a lot i don't know where was
you at a business when you hired
people like that
so uh i would say like when when we
started to
to really drive down as to what the
business plans are going to be and and
what the growth is going to look like
and also
um if you're if you're going to grow
you as the owner or owners or whatever
it may be of the company can't do that
yourself
um so okay how are you gonna do that and
i think that
the record strategy is clear and that
can work
is are you gonna get all your hires from
richter x possibly but it'd be super
expensive so
probably not the right thing to do um
so yeah again forget about the cost of
what
hiring that person is going to be if you
back that person and you think that
person is going to be good
and he's going to represent your brand
in the right way he's going to engage
with the right people
he's going to be convincing to you know
even even at 20 people even at 30 people
people will still have reasons why your
company is
not the right company for them or is too
small or is
whatever it can be anything it industry
is not interesting so i think that you
have to be able to then like communicate
like the reasons for why they should
join the company
um so that that head of talent is is
really really important
um to ensure so
again like from a growth perspective if
you're gonna grow
you need that person um how many of you
were there
how many of you were there when that
when you hired that person so so at a
point a point of
appointment uh eight or ten if i
remember quickly
yeah yeah so since we've hired that
person our growth is double
um in a quarter of the time
um and i think we get right as well
which is which is good
uh and from an operations perspective
same sort of thing i think like you know
your operation as such becomes bigger
because you've got more people to look
after
you've got more computers you've got
more um
whatever it can be anything um
in your business and and you know i
think that the
you can't underestimate the role that
operations has in in a business like
finance like luckily for me
uh my mum is is as i said like she has
10 of the company but she's also the
finance director of connecting experts
um so i was fortunate in that sense that
she was able to do that and she's done
that before in her life and she she
knows what to do there so
that's a really really important role
that i had staff since day one
luckily enough um more to that like
from an operations perspective okay
so if we like the industry
and people like new business owners and
people that come into it they talk about
like
innovation and they're the next best
thing and stuff like that so
why don't why doesn't the operations
person then become responsible
for how to innovate the office
and the back end and
um just the environment like itself like
since i've started from like for example
we used to write
our kpis on whiteboards now we have
like digital screens which you can see
on videos of our company now we talk
about
them as much as possible uh but like you
know they're digital screens they're on
a grass wall
they look fancy it's real time and all
that sort of stuff so
how can we innovate the environment to
innovate ourselves if that makes sense
like how can we make ourselves better by
our environment
um and that's what the operations role
is
is really really fundamental into the
table
yeah i love that and then again i think
i asked you this just because i think
again
people can if they if they are serious
about growth can feel get into the trap
of like ah
i'll get an operations person when i'm
here or it's not needed yet like
in your journey did you when did you
hire the operations person was you at
that sort of 10 head mark again and
you knew how important it was or yeah
yeah yeah i think at the start you can
manage a lot of that stuff
as a business owner you can manage you
can
you can deal with that it also depends
on what journey your business is taking
like are you
are you well funded by a big business to
set up a brand and then
you have a percentage of that branded
but you've got a million pounds behind
you to do that
obviously then you can rapidly attract
and build that infrastructure very very
quickly
if you're like what i was and you have
your own money and it's there's no one
backing you and you do it yourself then
you need to take more responsibility
well not more responsibility but you you
have more onus on
the cost and stuff like that so you have
to take slightly more control over those
types of things
at a time um but
once you get to a certain point and
again it's all this
all of these things i'll say about
reflection and self-awareness and
understanding
what's going on once you realize you
cannot do everything
which you cannot no one can you then
realize you need to get the right people
in the right spot in order to achieve
the next step of what your
objectives are and i think that was
really really important for us
yeah no amazing so how um
how has it been like dealing with a lot
of first then so like going on this
growth you've doubled
yeah you've gone from this shoebox room
of you and your brother smashing it out
you know 20 heads of you like how have
you i think sometimes people can
be quite worried again back to like
confidence or just worried around like
am i going to be able to
lead these people like am i the right
person i don't know like what's that
journey been like for you how have you
sort of because you're the person that's
walking down the track first
right so like how has that been
uh how's that been that is it's a
continual
it's a continual thing so like
recruitment's weird because
you could have your best month ever and
it'll be the best feeling ever but then
as soon as it becomes the first of the
next month
you start again and yeah and that can
work in the other way that can work in
the other way like if you have a really
really bad mind so then all of a sudden
you've got a fresh
fresh start and i think that
that's good and i think that when you
start to
people like the reason why i mentioned
it is because people don't always look
back at what they've done
they just look forward at what they're
gonna do that makes sense yeah um
and that's where like the reflection
part comes in and that's where like
really focusing on what you can do
better and how you can improve and
and again really going back to the start
of like my career i think that i don't
look at
okay so if i look at what i envisage
like i want us to open an office in the
u.s
um that's a huge milestone for me
personally
um i want us to get to x number of heads
whatever it may be
um i don't look at that and go
that's going to be super expensive how
are we gonna how are we gonna even do
that
who's gonna do it i'm obviously part of
me is thinking about that sort of stuff
but it's not like
the main thing that's that's like
pulling me down
so i i look at what i can impact
today and i look at what we need to be
doing
in order to achieve the next two three
four months late if we had had this
conversation
14 months ago no one would have been
able to forecast
what was going to happen no one um
in the world because it was impossible
and i think that
having contingency plans of okay it
isn't quite let's
focus on this but also being quite goal
orientated short medium long term
allows you to not worry about the big
picture and get
you know boggled down by it taking one
thing at a time and really focusing on
that
and really [ __ ] on how that can work
and how you can influence those
particular points
is is the most important i love that
um look as you come to an end here let's
just let's just talk about
specifically the last six or 12 months
i've seen you guys posting how you've
had a
really good year and these types of
things i guess
like obviously we would have all faced
their own challenges personal
professional
but yeah i don't know what if if i'm
asking you now in retrospective i don't
know we're still sort of working through
this but it seems like a lot
a lot of the floodgates have opened i
keep hearing that got loads of jobs new
candidates all these types of things
where it was different
12 40 months ago and i don't know what
what sort of things do you put it down
to
that enabled you guys to have your
best year since you've had or double
like still double because a lot of
people
yeah would have had the opposite mindset
and would have just
sort of scaled back and thought right
let's just survive like i don't know
what what
are some of the things you brought it
down to why you guys are able to
push on and create that success
yeah i think i think that the um
i think that's like it's testament to
like my team um
because without their like focus and
and uh thought process of wanting to do
that and and
again their ambition um it's not
achievable like if
if i want to do it but they don't we're
not going to do it yes it's impossible
so having them on board with that with
that idea and having them
you know really sort of again like again
go back to
being entrepreneurial and thinking about
their business and what their business
needs that was
from like game changer that's so
important
um we were fortunate that
without any sort of uh
like like for example chapman black was
one of our biggest competitors so that
they disappeared
that helped yeah imagine um although
although that when you cut when you cut
the head off
a lot of different businesses yeah quite
a few people
yeah yeah yeah that was uh that was the
next step which which
again like that's really good to see and
a lot of people that i work with now
have their own businesses which is
also like there's a healthy competition
now i can imagine as well
but back to the point like i think that
that gave us an opportunity to to sort
of
um push forward and push on and
our market didn't really suffer
necessarily because of it which was
again like being in tech convening like
um
the future as such that that allows that
it's a billion dollar industry that's
going to continue to develop
at a significant rate and don't think
that they were going to allow
anything to stop them so that also
helped us as well
um and coming back to like the
operations part like
now for days like having the
infrastructure having laptops having
cloud calls and all that sort of stuff
having all that stuff
that allows you to do that like 15 years
ago or even 10 years ago when i started
this wouldn't have been possible like
you wouldn't wouldn't have been able to
continue and uh
it would have had a far more detrimental
like knock-on effect to people's jobs
and
welfare and that's all stuff yeah i love
that so
look before i go into sort of the
quick-fire questions and finish
this off i've just got one or two more
things i want to ask you finally so
you've spoken a lot around getting the
right people you've worked really hard
on on getting that right so i guess what
i just wanted to hear from you
are what are the sort of free
non-negotiables for
the connecting experts culture that
they they're they're just the three
parts of your culture that
everyone sort of abides by that you
think his enable is going to continue to
enable you guys to grow
um the
the main like the biggest thing for us
in terms of like culture
in terms of of uh yeah
success whatever it is is positive
attitude um
like if you if you come in and you don't
have a positive attitude
um i can almost guarantee
you will struggle to succeed um
so for me number one positive dude
number two
like work right being you know really
really
focused on what you want to achieve and
how you want to do it and where you want
to go what stuff
like just just every day doing
everything you possibly can in terms of
work rate is super important
important um and and the third
because a lot of the people that we hire
are young and even if they weren't young
i think learning um you know being open
to learn and being open to
take not criticism but like critique um
and just wanting to develop as a person
that for me is so important
love that so before the quit fire
question round
i love asking this question and the
question is
like what do you think is the most
important kpi that contributes to
recruiter success
most important kpi active yeah
yeah like then you know everything
that's happening
best recruiters know everything that's
going on they know who the candidates
are
the that was always the good thing like
when i started it was like okay build
your top 250 but make sure you're
speaking to candidates on a
on a on a daily basis make sure you're
speaking to loads of people
um so you could say call time but
aimless call time is
is pointless um so after canada calls
and getting yourself
known by the candidates and knowing what
a good candidate looks like
is what the candidate is your product so
if you know what your product is and you
know how to sell it
yeah that's that's the thing you just
you just said that build your top 250
what's that what do you mean by that
oh we used to on paper we used to write
down
250 names of people within mobile
numbers and
whatever else um like for
business development so it's a bit like
okay write up your top 250 but make sure
decision makers but make sure you're
speaking to candidates on on the daily
basis
you know what's going on yeah love that
right final questions
so first question is okay um
if you could change the industry what
would you improve
uh the like cowboy
ness to it if that makes sense yeah
yeah absolutely so i don't know if
you're much of a reader but i want to
know what what book have you read that's
had the biggest impact on you
could be something you watched or maybe
listen to if you're not a reader
uh i don't i don't well the biggest
thing that i read
now is the economist um and
and just gen general news about what's
going on in the world i think it's
important
to open up your mind and to see how and
what is happening
um but would i said that 10 years ago
probably not i would have watched
something like
wall street or something like that
right i'm interested to hear this one
mate what did you spend
your first biggest commission paycheck
on
uh so i love watches
um so even now
that's what i would that's what i'd
always spend money on
watches what was the first watch then
mate cher what was the first watch that
you bought with the commission
so the the the first so the first watch
i bought was a
was a roadster party a roadster but like
that wasn't necessarily
it was it was nice but it wasn't a big
watch but like when i was when i got
like a massive paycheck
for a big quarter i did and i went and
bought an aldemar
um and yeah
that was like the first like big thing
that i had
love that right final question what
what's the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career or business
can keep it business what's ultimate
goal for your recruitment business
uh it's a good question um it will
100 evolve as time develops but i would
say that the first
goal the biggest three the ultimate goal
for us
is to be
worldwide renowned for what we do um
it's not about size it's not about
revenue
uh those byproducts of being as a
business successful
um so i would say for us to be
an international footprint to be
recognized however that will be
we'll have to work on that over time but
being recognized
for being for delivering world-class you
know services and talent
to the businesses that we work with that
would be like for me the ultimate
goal on an international you know scale
ross thanks spin that's a pleasure
thanks for coming on
yeah no problem thank